you say socialism is dead so what's next
um i don't know fascism
[Laughter]
yeah i mean perhaps tim i hate all these
labels i think they're all so fake
i know they are gay and fake um
you know i was like listening i actually
listened to um
the the episode you did with candace
owens right yes
who by the way i am the and i've never
said this but since you said
you want to come out and say something
i'll say something i am the father of
her
child i'm the father of candace's child
i decided to father a child with her
that must be great for your career well
it was very it was
harder than i thought i mean i've done
it a few times with women i'm
i've had sex with women none of them
would say it was great but they were all
preceded by
five course dinners and carriage rides
to the park so i mean really
yeah that's the whole package you're not
a what's it called a gold star gay is
that is that what it's called
yes one who's never gone near a woman no
there's there's several
long island women who've you know had
the privilege of being near me
what up so you listen yeah what did you
think about that episode cause people
got mad at me that i didn't like
i don't know scream at her or something
i mean i don't know she she's really
cute and small i like her she she's
zippy
and pepe she reminds me of black poglia
you know she has a special
energy i don't know if she's coming i
don't want to say she's camille pogba i
think we might have to slow down with
that
but i do like the energy i do like she's
pepe
yeah i mean like in her and in her like
vibe and her general energy
i think she say she has like the same
kind of
um energy but i think like the thing
that she gets wrong and that a lot of
people on the right get wrong
fundamentally
is they talk about like radical leftism
and
this isn't radical leftism it's just
liberalism
like all the radical leftists are just
liberals right
this is the extreme this is the logical
conclusion logical extreme
of taking like the individual centric
human rights
based framework and bringing it to like
this extreme conclusion you have like
the um
you know whatever the war on gender the
war on the family like all of these
things that we didn't think would be a
thing
this is just you know i think it's very
tactical
also on on the part of
like the liberal establishment and a lot
of people on the right want to
want to see it as like a kind of radical
left
phenomenon and it's really not you know
i don't think there is any meaningful
socialism or leftism in the united
states of america
no there doesn't seem to be much and and
uh you know obviously they're all
these these things are all you know
unfortunate terms but
uh you know in terms of of the most
aggressively liberal people are also
very much careerists in a very boring
uh office they love office politics they
love you know these meaningless awards
they give to each other they love
committees they love
nonsense there's something very sexless
and sad about that particular iteration
of liberalism that culture even though
they're hyper obsessed with sex and
sexual freedom no one seems like they're
having it it seems like a very
strange uh churlish kind of
you know you know hyper focused on
career i mean everybody's got the
attitude of like
you know um somebody that wants to be
the ceo
of the public space that's what it feels
like everybody just wants to own
a certain you know a certain uh has
certain turf and this is where i stand
and just [ __ ] you know sling my
half-baked ideas and uh and as as a
comic it's just watching comedians
become this
has been sort of sad because i knew a
lot of these people or
i had you know had limited interactions
with them but i had appreciated some of
their work and like
you know chelsea handler used to write
some really funny books about her
[ __ ] and they were funny and you know
she used to write
you know about uh [ __ ] herself and
whatever
having sex with midgets or whatever it
was and
now it's she's doing documentaries about
white privilege and i feel like
it's just it's just it's hard to see
that
change i don't know what i don't know
what to do with that i don't know what
to do with jimmy kimmel saying that
the people trading gamestop stock are
russians i don't know why he's doing
that i don't know
i don't know what it does for him i i
don't i don't understand i mean some of
them
probably are i well look i mean i think
just like
you ignore it and you do your own thing
because i think there's enough
of like an extra institutional um
population of people that
they have you know like somebody like
joe rogan right has way more influence
than any of these people and they know
it which is why they're always trying to
like
get him branded as like a fascist or
a white supremacist or transphobe or
whatever right um
but you know you know and another thing
you know that that she said on
on your on that episode was like like
right that like
uh leftism is like a religious call for
for people who
wake up in the morning wanting to get
outraged or some uh something who
who make themselves like deliberately
unattractive like this sort of thing
and and really what they're doing in her
mind was that they
they were sort of like um they wanna
they they wanna um i forgot how she put
it i
wrote it down somewhere i don't know if
i could she
was saying finish enjoys her life and
that people want her to be enraged and
she goes to the grocery store and she
sees oh what do they have in the meat
aisle and people are like mad at anchor
by my
pancakes yeah yeah the pancakes right
and she said yeah their mission is to
undo things that people historically
never
had a problem with or thought even to
have a problem with
and you know cs spot the lie
like she's not wrong but that's
fundamentally even too charitable
because what they're really doing
i think is so much worse which is taking
credit for
fighting these kind of simpler battles
of the past
that have already been meaningfully
settled um
far in advance by by forces outside of
their control
mainly um economic forces and economic
processes you know so they want to take
credit for like
accelerating certain battles like the
battle you know like all this like
gender uh discourse trans rights and
stuff like that
and basically those things have were
already kind of like
economically baked in the cake that
people would become
kind of less gender binary as women
enter the workforce
right you know what i'm saying right so
many of these forces
are like you said brilliantly out of uh
people's control they're not exactly
uh malleable uh they seem to be
sort of static forces that just shape
the culture in different ways
and that manifests in in you know
different ways some some of those ways
are incredibly annoying
some less so